..
Let's try other verbal tasks. This first
is a classic.
The Briton has $ 2 and 25 cents in pennies and dimes.
If it has a total of 40 coins, how many
has every value?
First define the variables.
The letter n will be the number of dimes.
...
And letter d the number of pennies.
We know he has a total of $ 2 and $ 25 cents.
in dimes and dimes.
How much is a coin from each value?
So if we take the number of dimes, everyone has
value of $ 0.05.
So the number of pennies by 0.05 is how much money
they represent pennies, plus the amount of money
that represent dimes.
So we have d dimes.
Each has a value of $ 0.1.
So that's the total amount of money we have.
If we have 5 dimes, multiply by 0.05 five and get 0.25.
If we had 4 dimes, it would make 0.40 and add up
it together.
Our assignment says the total amount we have
are $ 2 and 25 cents.
This first claim can be transferred
into this equation.
We have a certain number of dimes and
a certain number of dimes.
Multiply by 0.05 the number of dots and 0.1 the number of dimes
and we get 2.25.
Now the second statement - we have a total of 40 coins.
And we assume they're just dimes and dimes,
no more coins.
So a total of 40 coins, that is, the number
the number of dimes plus a total of 40.
So dimes plus dimes - equal to 40.
This tells us this information.
So we have two equations with two unknowns and
two ways to calculate it.
We can construct a system of two equations and subtract one
equation from the other.
Or we can make a substitution.
Let's try it.
This is a more common way.
So - what we do: we solve the equation for d.
We could solve it for any unknown, but
we find out how much d is and what comes out
we replace d here in this equation.
First, we subtract n from both sides of the equation -
- Here we go.
Minus n plus this, minus n.
Of course, this has to be deducted from both sides and will stay with us,
that d equals 40 - n.
Now we take the result
and substitute it in the second equation.
d is equal to 40 minus
number of dots.
And we can put it back in d.
The first equation will now be 0.05 times
number of dots plus 0.1 times
number of dimes.
So we already know that the number of dimes is
equal to 40 minus n.
We learned that from the second statement.
So instead of d I substitute 40 minus n.
That's the number of dimes we have. It's 40 minus
the number of dimes, and that equals two dollars and twenty-five cents.
And now we can try to solve it for n.
So we get 0.05 times n plus 0.1 times 40 - that's 4.
See how we multiply it.
0.1 times 40, that is 4 minus 0.1 times n,
this is how I multiplied the parenthesis, and that equals two dollars twenty five cents.
And what do we do next?
Now we either take 0.05 and subtract 0.1 from it
depending on how we want it - when we subtract these two members
we get to minus - 0.05 minus 0.1
- by subtracting we get a negative number
plus 4 - this four still remains
and equals 2.25
Now we can subtract 4 from both sides of the equation
We get minus 0.05n equals (if we subtract 4
left - the four must go away - subtract 4
even here; 2.25 minus 4 - that is minus 1.75
OK.
Now we multiply both sides of the equation by minus one,
to make it easier, so we have it
plus and plus.
And then we divide both sides by 0.05.
We could just divide both sides minus 0.05
but I like everything positive.
So, when we divided everything by 0.05, we got n equal to 1.75
refracted 0.05.
So let's divide it.
I'll write it in a different color.
So we divide by 1.75 / 0.05. Multiply first
numerator and denominator stem.
Let's move two decimal places
so we will have 5
and 175
It's the same as 175 over 5.
17 divided by five are 3.
3 times five is fifteen
2 on
We write 5.
25.
25 divided by 5 is 5.
5 times 5 is twenty-five.
We have no rest.
So it equals 35.
thus n is equal to 35 and we can find out how much d is equal to d
40 minus n.
thus, d is equal to 40 minus 35, which is 5.
So we have 5 dimes and 35 dimes.
And to make sure it's right,
35 pennies gives how many?
35 times 5 cents
is 175 cents, or seventy-five cents.
$ 1 and 75 cents in pennies.
35 times 5 or 0.05,
as you want.
So this must be 5.
And this is going to be 50 cents in dimes.
1.75 plus 0.5 - this is a total of two dollars twenty-five cents.
Let's calculate one more verbal role.
We have patterns of squares.
Here we see them.
How many squares are in the twelfth pattern?
Let's look at it.
This is the first, this second and the third figure.
Here's a single square
here are two times two, but this block is missing
right here.
So let's look at it.
One way to look at it is 2 times 2,
and here 3 times 3, but from here 2 times 2 are taken out.
So the next one will be 4 times 4
and the removed block will be 3 times 3.
I would say one way to describe the number of squares -
- actually, the simplest way, we don't have to
don't even think. Let's see, here we have three and then we have
3 minus 1 here.
Highlight it with a different color.
Here we have 2 and here 2 minus 1.
And here we have 1 and 1 minus 1.
So zero.
In general, the number of squares for any n will be
n plus n minus 1.
Which is 2n minus1.
And it works.
2n-1
2 times 3 minus 1 is 5
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
It works with these three shapes.
So for the twelfth pattern, where n equals 12, that will be
2 times 12 minus 1, ie 24 minus 1
which equals 23 squares in the twelfth pattern.
Although I said we will only calculate one more task, but let's go one more,
when we started.
Grace rode a bike at 12 miles an hour.
An hour later, Dan took the same route at 15 miles an hour.
How long will it take before
Grace will finish?
So let's mark the time Grace is going, like t.
Or better
t will be Dan's driving time.
How long will it take to ride Grace?
Dan left an hour later.
So, whatever the number, Grace must go
one hour longer.
So t plus 1 equals Grace driving time.
When this is 0, this will be 1.
She will already have a 1 hour drive.
And we have to remember that the distance is equal
Speed ​​times time.
So Dan's distance will be 15 miles an hour
times time in hours.
That's the distance Dan went.
And then Gracina's distance - we can call her g,
or let's say D for Grace, it's also her distance traveled -
- It'll be 12 miles an hour.
So her time will be t plus one.
It goes one hour longer
than Dan.
12 times t plus 1.
And the point they meet is a point
in which both sides are equal.
Dan's distance traveled will be equal
the distance Grace had driven.
So these two items must be equal.
15 times t - that's how far Dan came -
- must be equal
12 times t plus 1.
And that's how far Grace came.
And remember, its time must always be one hour more
than Dan's.
So let's count the time.
We have 15t equals 12t plus 1.
12t plus 1.
And then we subtract 12 - excuse 12t plus 12 -
we don't want to make a mistake here.
When we subtract 12 on both sides of the equation, we get
3t equals 12.
Divide both sides by three - moving it a little lower -
And we find that t equals 4.
So after 4 hours, after 4 hours,
caught up with Dan Grace.
This is Dan and if his journey lasted for 4 hours, Grace had to
go 6 hours.
6 hours is Grace's time.
And Dan after 4 hours - 4 times 15
drove 60 miles
And Grace - excuse me, she went 1 hour earlier so it
it's not six o'clock, just one hour longer than Dan.
So it's 5, it's been a total of 5 hours.
Grace was pedaling for 5 hours at 12 miles an hour.
And she drove, again, 60 miles.
So they met exactly after sixty miles.
..